monsieur que vous nous présentez
l'astragale après vous êtes présenté
lui-même
yuan
non juste une affaire de famille je suis
émue fière d'accompagner
et je suis le chef des missions en deux
nos vies raciale le bateau a été fermé à
la compagnie générale transatlantique
le bateau a des caractéristiques
suivantes 60 mètres de longueur 13 m de
largeur qu'en tirant peu de quelques
piges il est équipé pour faire des
interventions sûres
miss monde et tous les travaux aussi
alimenté au prochain procès l'année at
il été construits ce bateau est un
bateau d'origine anglaise qui a été
modifié en 1962 remodifier en 1967 est
il unique en europe en europe dans son
genre et il va t-il beaucoup de ce genre
là dans le monde dans le monde les
batteries et quelle est la future
mission de ce bateau messieurs puisque
nous connaissons déjà une des missions
qu'il a effectuées dernièrement oui ce
navire est mise en place par la société
l2 qui entreprend un groupe
l'expérimentation de la gascogne
récemment nous une plateforme
actuellement nous allons partir de cette
plateforme poser une canalisation et
nous avons confié cette mission
l'entrepreneur gtn présent départ mais
c'est le reste comment procédez-vous
pour poser une canalisation est ce le
même principe qu'un câblier qui déroule
tout simplement son table dance est
absolument impossible de procéder comme
avec un table d'arcade s'enroule dans
les cultures eu beaucoup trop rigide et
risquerait de se briser on ne peut
procéder pour les cabinets comme les
claviers qui avaient des tuyaux de tous
qui y mène nous avons là un tuyau de 2
cm de diamètre et nous allons
expérimenter une méthode mise au point
par la société vivante entre marseille
qui constituera d'ailleurs une première
mondiale puisque jamais encore
un tube avec ce procédé la part 100
mètres de là quel endroit elle
déposerait vous ce livre dont le partira
de la plateforme qui a déjà été émis
dans l'air du temps et partira dans le
nord-est sur une longueur de 2 km
combien de temps tenté vous m pour
déposer ses crillon c'est extrêmement
variés de la méthode doit permettre de
le poser rapidement mais des problèmes
de services inc qui sont avancés à vrai
risque d'allonger la durée en principe
entre 15 et la pose elle-même ne devrait
pas durer plus de 48 heures
le sanguinaire pouvez vous nous dire ce
rapidement quelles sont les différentes
missions que ce bateau mais d'effectuer
ce navire les missions multiples nous
avons commencé l'an dernier par faire du
forage en militaires année actuellement
nous avons posé une plateforme nous
posons l'ubaye et nous finirons dans le
golfe de gascogne par quelques missions
de carottage et de poses d'ancrage de
l'explosif c'est à dire qu'il est
capable de remplir un certain nombre
d'émissions et que chaque fois qu'une
mission est remplie confiez-vous modifié
l' usine car on peut l'appeler une usine
oui on préfère l'appeler même un
laboratoire le temps
combien important pour transformer le
bâtiment est reporté pour une nouvelle
mission pensez vous qu'il faille en
construire d'autres de ses bateaux où je
crois oui pour faire progresser la
recherche option
plusieurs types de sites de bateaux la
vie à bord étaient à l'agréable en
chansons cette conversation oui elle est
très agréable malheureusement et farid
fatemi plateau de la colle applications
propres motifs
et infini qui a pas mal de pertes
la 6ème édition
quel est le plus gros problèmes qui se
posent à leur goût à vous tous lorsque
vous êtes en mer est le mauvais temps
est ce le travail la difficulté quoi
c'est toujours le mauvais temps parce
que la tenue du bateau et restent
incertaines partir du moment où la houle
dépasse de loin ce n'est pas de la faute
du bateau c'est de la faute de la
précision des méthodes que l'on doit
s'employer dit ne permet pas des
dépassements dans les bateaux vous
reparler de précision il s'agit de quel
ordre dizaines de mètres 100 mètres ou
plus ou moins que ça par exemple pour la
méthode de la poste de pipelife on est
tenu a maintenant le bateau dans un
rayon de 2 ou 3 mètres autour d'un point
fixe si l'on ne veut pas risquer de
briser le tuyau héros forage en forage
non nan mais le principe d'environ 6% de
la profondeur en général se fait alors
de quelques et renaître en déplacement
latéral
mais l'ancrage de ce bâtiment est
suffisant il permet de maintenir cette
fois ci
et quant à parier ou le lundi soir
dimanche soir ou lundi matin au plus
tard en de reset lundi matin sur le site
pour commencer l'expérience wind
campagne de 15 jours 15 jours 15 jours
après merci messieurs